the current left seems to be a product
of the 1960s how I left how I left which
intended to liberate customs and ideas
from a restrictive society became
restrictive in its own towards
politically incorrect ideas did it
become part of the establishment yeah
actually it did it did in part become
part of the establishment and this is I
mean this is a point that that we've
been making for years since before
Evergreen blew up really that in part
liberals should be celebrating and
recognized for the fact that many of the
things that they before our time but you
know we were fighting for with regard to
actual civil rights and you know second
wave feminism not the later waves but
you know and and you know just equality
of opportunity for people regardless of
demographics and you know and things
like restricted working hours and child
labor laws like all of these are
actually wins for liberals who became
the establishment to some degree they
became the establishment becoming the
establishment makes you conservative
unless you have a very great strength of
character and I don't mean that
conservatives don't have strength of
character but what I mean is that when
you have a lot to lose your tendency to
want to conserve the things that got it
for you is so high that you don't
necessarily update when you should so
that process has as I think I did a
pretty good job on Joe Rogan's program
of explaining that process has frozen
normal regular folks out of a lot of the
well-being that society generates and
they're pissed and that's why they're in
the street and they're not wrong it is
rigged against the minutes not evenly
rigged threw it against some populations
more than others which explains the sort
of fusion of occupy with black lives
matter but the point also though and
the point also is intersectionality is a
new solution to an old problem and
unfortunately the old problem is when
you don't have growth to offer people
who are demanding growth when growth
makes us feel good because things are
getting better all right and you don't
have any growth to offer them you figure
out how you can get some phony growth
and you can get phony growth in a number
of ways you can steal it from the future
and make the future worse in order to
make the present feel better or you can
steal it from people who can't defend
themselves so we've got a demographic
problem in which corrupt elites in both
parties are not sharing well being that
they have earned through what Jim Rupp
would call money on money returns what I
would say rent-seeking but those people
are not ready to share and instead of
sharing what they've decided to do is
take people who are aggrieved and point
them at people who can't defend
themselves it's not that different from
what happened in Weimar Germany blaming
the Jews justified stealing stuff from
them and giving it to other people who
wanted growth and the German apparatus
couldn't provide it right so this is an
old trick now in this case the
intersectional version is new the
intersectional version says you can take
it from white people because they
deserve it
that's what it is and the point is
that's cheaper than sharing I know my
sister-in-law makes a point like this
I've been making that point for a very
long time that instead of sharing what
has been hoarded you can point people at
other people who are now allowed to
steal from and you know I mean you can
just take that sentence and map it onto
all of the things that we are now told
are desirable why would you get get rid
of the police well certainly going to
allow you to steal from people you've
now been told you're entitled to steal
from right it's not that complicated so
is that the revolution you want sure as
hell ain't the one I want
[Music]